et on va démarrer par un sujet que vous
connaissez bien
jean michel cohen puisque chaque année
en france il ya cinquante mille
personnes qui ont recours à une
chirurgie de l'obésité
je sais d'ailleurs que vous avez écrit
un livre avec guy carlier et qu'il en
parle dans ce livre pourtant ces
interventions sont loin d'être sans
risques le 20 heures de france 2 a
enquêté en france les critères de la
chirurgie bariatrique sont strictes elle
concerne l'obésité sévère doit être un
dernier recours après six mois de suivi
médical sans résultat et le patient
opéré doit être suivi à vie un cadre pas
toujours respectée par les médecins pour
ces deux femmes opérées par le même
chirurgien les suites ont été
cauchemardesques
avant l'opération nelly pèse 98 kilos
pour 1 mètre 66 elle n'est pas en
obésité sévère son chirurgien opère tout
de même selon elle un mois et demi
seulement après son premier rendez vous
n'est lié affirme aujourd'hui qu'il ne
lui a jamais expliqué clairement les
risques
j'ai perdu 44 kg en neuf mois dans la
vie de tous les jours et ben ça se
traduit avec des diarrhées incessantes
c'est comme si j'ai les castro pendant
trois ans alors je me vais évidemment me
tourner vers vous jean-michel cinquante
mille opérations par an la france est le
troisième pays au monde à pratiquer ce
type de chirurgie il faut savoir
qu'elles sont remboursés par la sécurité
sociale en en france et en l'occurrence
parfois on a le sentiment comme on
l'entend dans ce témoignage que et des
personnes qui ne sont pas en obésité
dite morbide bénéficie quand même de ces
chirurgies est ce que vous estimez que
c'est normal parce qu'elles sont malgré
tout en souffrant c'est ce que vous
dites que là il ya une dérive parce que
j'imagine quand même qu'une opération
telle que celle ci s'est vraiment anodin
non mais d'abord il faut rappeler que
pour avoir une opération de cette nature
il faut un avoir été en échec pendant
six mois en traitement diététique
deuxièmement avoir une obésité
conséquente morbide avec un imc
supérieur à 35
ça veut dire que vous avez vraiment 40
50 kilos de trop troisièmement avoir une
consultation de psychiatrie pour
vérifier que ça va pas avoir des
conséquences psychologiques
là on a beaucoup de problèmes à l'heure
actuelle c'est que il ya des gens qui de
façon inconséquente opère d'autres
personnes qui ne justifient pas d'une
chirurgie comme celle là et donc nous
quand on fait cette opération on mesure
le risque par rapport aux bénéfices il
ya un risque dans une intervention
chirurgicale et on a un deuxième
problème c'est des gens qui partent à
l'étranger maintenant pour payer moins
cher
r pour faire ce type de chirurgie à
n'importe quel prix c'est à dire pour
eux mêmes en prenant tous les risques
ça va on imagine donc pas ce que vous
parlez de ces chirurgies notamment à
l'étranger que ce sont parce que
normalement elles sont prises en compte
elles sont prises en charge par la
cellule sociale
mais si ça n'a pas été pris en compte ça
veut dire que l'obésité n'était pas
suffisamment importante et donc on prend
un risque supplémentaire en allant à
l'étranger exactement et dernière chose
qu'on dit pas aux gens c'est que dans la
plupart de ces chirurgies maintenant
qu'on a du recul même quand les gens
perdent 50 kg on a les reprises de poids
au bout d'un certain temps de l'ordre de
20%
donc ça veut dire il faut que ce soit un
vrai professionnel qui disent ben oui
faut vraiment y aller cette fois ci
parce que vous méritez de le faire sinon
on aura des problèmes
voilà mais il ya toujours eu des gens
peu scrupuleux
l'argent qu'on lui demandait ce que vous
pourriez nous expliquer tout de même les
différentes opérations parce
qu'effectivement il y a alors on entend
parler de ce livre on a deux grosses
opérations allaient la première grosse
opération c'est ce qu'on appelle le
bypass ça veut dire qu'on coupe une
partie de l'estomac pour le ramener au
stade d'un manchon comme si on avait un
estomac d'adolescents et puis on ajoute
à ça une deuxième opération consiste à
dériver l'intestin donc à raccourcir
l'intestin de telle façon à diminuer
l'absorption des aliments ça c'est
première opération il ya des gens voyous
qui dit je vais vous faire un mini
bypass bah moi je sais pas ce que ça
veut dire un mini bypass et la deuxième
opération c'est ce qu'on appelle la
sleeve ça veut dire qu'on réduit juste
l'estomac quasiment des deux tiers et
puis c'est tout y est réversible celle
ci elle est belle et paris bercy mais
l'estomac il peut avec le temps
reprendre plus de volume c'est une poche
qui va se dilater est ce qu'il faut dire
également c'est que quand on fait un by
pass
on sera suivie jusqu'à la fin de ses
jours parce que comme il ya une
malabsorption bas il faudra prendre des
tables vitamines des tas de médicaments
jusqu'à fin de ses jours donc il faut
vraiment le justifier pour le faire
d'accord très bien est-ce que vous
souhaitez réagir les uns les autres sur
ces opérations qu'on pratique on est le
troisième pays au monde en france à
pratiquer c'est pas simple pas le
troisième pays en europe au nom mais on
est leaders ou s'il fallait dire qu'on a
été les premiers à mettre en place ces
systèmes
on a peut-être été les premiers mais il
ya aussi une chose qui est réelle c'est
que le système ne contrôle pas les abus
ni de la part des patients ni de la part
des médecins c'est garder les bases à
plus de l'un que de l'autre
je pense qu'on est dans une telle
dictature du corps du corps parfait
qu'aujourd'hui la jeune femme ou le
jeune homme qui a envie de perdre 15 ou
20 kg c'est vrai qu'il n'a plus envie de
se faire chier à faire un régime qui va
durer
rappelons à savoir si ça marche vous
repensez une opération et on sait qu'une
opération c'est pas anodin c est tout
aussi responsable a effectivement entre
vous propose un petit bypass sympa tu
vas voir c'est une petite opération et
ce talent je trouve que les médecins
minimise quand même vraiment ils ont
raison de le faire parce que le système
leur permet tous ces abus c'est qu'il ya
une autorité qui n'existe pas pardon
jean-louis mais au dessus de vous les
médecins les plus jeunes c'est l'ordre
de 800 normalement toute ma vie mon nom
mais là ça concerne plus lors des
médecins sur ce type de quand il ya un
incident de cette nature là le médecin
il a une obligation de moyens ça va être
un procès en justice ça va être une
indemnisation par la science ne dis pas
qu'on est dieu c'est la pression des
gens qui fait ça il ya une telle
détresse dans la prise de poids
franchement il adapte nature du corps
que les instagram euse comme toi nous
fournissant en exhibant leur belle forme
sur les allées dire par là c'est parfait
ça voulait dire par là que parfois en
médecins entre guillemets subit là une
telle pression qu'ils sont passionnés
par opérer même si mais oui il ne
devrait pas opérer
j'appelle à la rescousse le docteur
moggi c'est pas vrai que sa tendre
enfance limite pression très tôt j'ai
plein de pression mais c'est aussi notre
honneur de ne pas céder à cette pression
quand on fait 10 12 15 ans d'études moi
je ne prends pas la pression que le
patient peut m j'essaie de mettre une
barrière et j'ai un ami chirurgien qui
pratiquent cette chirurgie et qui fait
signer un contrat thérapeutique en
disant vous et devait être suivi à vie
et je vous préviens vous risquez de
mourir sur la table le risque est
toujours derrière vous risquez d'avoir
des fistules vous risquez de faire des
hémorragies vos skis si si vous êtes
d'accord
vous signez comme quoi vous donner
l'information en détresse en temps ce
qu'on lui dit à ce moment là n'en est ce
qu'il est et nantes non non non parce
que les gens bien hiver vous qui sont en
échec de perte de poids pendant des mois
et des mois qu'ils subissent
effectivement cette dictature du corps
parfait en fait le ils s'en foutent
parce qu'ils s'imaginent que le médecin
il va tout traiter maintenant les gens
peu scrupuleux
heureusement il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont moins ce que beaucoup moins de gens
peu scrupuleux que de gens ce qu
pleurait mais il ya des gens peu
scrupuleux qui font ce type
d'intervention et c'est ce qui crée les
scandales régulièrement et bâti nous ce
que vous en pensez avec le hashtag sécu
des lt est ce que comme caroline vous
dites il ya à la fois parfois des
dérives mais qui sont de la faute du du
médecin des patriciens et également du
patient qui met trop de pression ou bien
et est ce que vous avez vous même
peut-être d anecdote à nous raconter ou
des témoignages à nous faire parvenir le
hashtag ccq dlt